so fun man how's it going what seven are
you I'm doing guest in awhile you're uh
I gotta say I finished the whole season
last night and you're doing great work
in this man like it's there's like
nuance it's really textured um what was
it like getting to get back into this
character and were you excited yeah yeah
thank you
um yeah man I I can't begin to tell you
how excited I was to just be invited
back for the second season
honestly um you know for me you know so
much was just left on the table so much
was left up in the air as far as Walter
and man I I just felt like probably how
the audience felt and then selfishly I
wanted to come back and be able to you
know tie up some of those loose ends so
just incredibly incredibly happy to be
part of the season yeah I mean the first
season was was such a huge success for
you so you guys are the Golden Globes
which is an amazing thing as well was it
a relief sort of knowing that the
reception for season one was so good
that I give you confidence going into
season two uh I guess you could say that
yeah you certainly knowing that there
you know that there was a fan base that
you know was following it and really
paying attention you know of course you
want to be a part of a show like that um
so yeah for me obviously you know
there's a lot of things that I again
selfishly wanted to do as an actor but I
again I just felt like to show me
closure and and Walter storyline maybe
needed closure and and the second season
gave me the best opportunity to do that
so where do we find Walter this time
around when we start off
what's his mindset like I think that
when season 2 starts we start with a
very curious Walter you know Walter
that's unsure of certain things that's
happened in the past he has a lot of
questions and and and slowly he goes
from you know having these questions to
getting these answers and you
and then wanting more you know
ultimately wanting to - right some of
the wrongs it's a place in that first
season yeah and season two like setting
wise even the way that the episodes
moved is very different from the season
one can you explain a bit like what what
those changes are and maybe why they'll
change you take place yeah I think you
know a big part of it is we had a
different director this season Kyle
Patrick Alvarez who really you know put
his own unique stamp on the show which
was incredible for me to see you know
just aesthetically but I also think that
you know the first season was quite
contained it felt like you know it was
all happening in sort of the same same
space
this season you know where we're out and
about you know in the in the forest and
and and by the lake and and it's it's a
lot of really really cool stuff so I
think the show's will probably a little
less contained this season you've had an
opportunity in the last few years to
work with like real powerhouses and
Janelle Monae is one of those performers
that transcends like any kind of label
what was it like working those scenes
with her being with her on set
I loved it I was a big fan of Janelle's
music even before getting to work with
her we had met a couple times in the
past and you know I got to express that
and and you know so there's been a
mutual respect between us and and when
they call me and told me that she had
been cast honestly I really couldn't
have thought of a better person for that
role you know just seeing some of the
acting stuff she was starting to do
moonlight etc you know I just need this
she was special and I just knew that
this show would give her a real
opportunity to display her her gifts and
so I think the world would be pleasantly
surprised with what she doesn't think
when you're when you're on set with
somebody whose work is like so
contagious like I do find yourself
stopping yourself from becoming her
songs low-key under your breath like
there's lady I may have had a day or two
like that don't tell her though Ballack
you work with Julia really closely last
year and she is an exec on on the show
still um did she talk to you going in
season two about where the direction was
going did you guys keep in touch between
seasons about what you're gonna do and
what you want to express with this
season yeah we definitely talked
periodically um you know I think more so
than anything julie has just been so
encouraging she really hasn't you know
been been going around telling anyone
what to do I think she's just been you
know it was just a really positive
uplifting you know life for us she she
actually stopped by the set one day when
we were filming this season and and I
don't know just just crazy to see her
come back you know such a light always
so you know she's she's a cool close
friend hopefully she's proud of what
we've done daddy let this show this
season soon specifically is playing
around with that you can you know sort
of commoditize the idea of your memory
as a wild one if you lost your memory if
you couldn't get it back what would your
friends and family need to do to get
like your memory back is there something
that would show
you back into into place it put on ESPN
you start watching some sport it's at a
probably jog a holly jolly